不要把我自己成年了之后的一些不良的习性和不好的行为都推到原生家庭上去，
因为我们之所以是成年人，
就是因为我们有了自我修复、
自我修正的能力，
我们才成为了一个成年人。
我今年35岁，
去年结的婚，
微玉。
我和老公在同一个小县城，
老公在外地工作，
现在跟着他在外地租房，
偶尔做做兼职。
我有一个哥哥，
父母和哥哥在一起做小买卖，
虽然供我上大学，
在我毕业以后，
经济上偶尔小资小助，
但资助大多倾向哥哥偏安养儿防老的传统家庭。
父亲性格暴躁强势，
总是让我心跳的过多干涉我的决定，
争执激烈时打工而辱骂过我，
让我一步步想逃离大学毕业自己去的大城市打工，
但期间父母总希望回老家相亲结婚，
我表达过想在大城市独立工作，
但他们一边支持一边高强度催婚，
总说为我好，
但生活中忽略我的感受，
想法让我迷茫。
我母亲偏袒我哥哥，
让我一度委屈、
焦虑、
抑郁。
父母总催婚，
我也想逃离原生家庭，
所以恋爱半年闪婚可能仓促吧。
当时公婆大多数钱存的死期，
所以他们私下商量，
婚礼钱签由我老公出，
等去年年底到期再给他。
这是我结婚前一周，
她总花钱，
我问她才得知的，
有些不舒服，
但考虑是婚前，
而且好事将近，
我就没那么计较。
结完婚，
老公存款正好清零，
说实话感觉不安，
公婆就此事也没说什么，
感觉不受尊重，
相处起来也微妙，
不少不舒服的事也不敢反驳，
怕公婆生气，
不给钱了，
疫情他们单位也降薪，
我也想找安稳工作，
手上也没钱，
就挺反感催生的，
都头疼。
我和老公会吵架，
气急了我拧他，
他都会还手，
还冷暴力逃避，
从不低头。
我觉得他不爱我，
被催多了她也会动摇，
想生孩子，
我会告诉他钱的问题，
让我不安，
要不他和父母沟通一下说清楚，
但他就会沉默逃避，
我总觉得他不太负责任，
还有点大男子主义。
我过年钱到期了，
正好赶上我们俩要买车，
婆婆给钱让我们去买车，
虽然多给了几万，
但婚礼的钱绝口不提，
对外借，
也宣称她想让我们俩买的车，
我闹不清。
清楚，
坚持让老公把钱说清楚，
她拖到临走前这支吾问婆婆结婚花了多少，
婆婆一句那么清楚，
她又沉默了。
经过这些事，
我们的感情淡淡的，
一直没有买车，
也没有敢生孩子。
两个月前，
婆婆又催生我和他说了我们经济上的稳定一些再生，
希望他能理解，
也问他伤了帮不帮我带，
因为我想上班嘛。
他一会儿说可以送回老家，
他来带我，
说我不想和孩子分开，
一会儿又说出来帮我们带。
经过之前的事儿，
我也不全信了，
而且他们的经济状况我也不敢全信。
我多问了句，
结婚的五金算是妈妈给买的还是老公给买的？
当时是老公掏的钱，
我婆婆却说是他们家给我买的，
而且那是结婚前，
结婚后经济上要跟我们分着。
我感觉自己是个外人，
被算计，
最近我和我老公吵架，
也是一如既往的，
他什么都不管，
得过且过，
在争执时，
我气急了，
打了他一巴掌，
提出分手，
他说嫌我打他了，
他很累，
然后又说他耽误我，
也同意分手，
我该不该分？
如果不分，
我还想让他把那个老家的楼，
结婚的楼房卖了，
在外边买一个。
因为他可。
你确定在一个省范围活动，
家里的总空着，
在外也老租房，
经济压力也大，
现在你自己是有个什么工作呀，
大概一个月能挣多少钱呀？
就是超市的一些零售啊，
一个月大概四五千，
结婚的时候是有彩礼的，
18万8彩礼在你手上是吧？
对，
在我手上，
平时他的工资也交在我手上，
我们一跟他妈妈就是接触，
我俩就吵架之类，
我就头老疼又焦虑，
我净做噩梦，
天天，
你现在手上一共有多少存款，
我爸妈也陪嫁了，
几万，
大概20多万吧，
然后我们两口子10万块钱吧，
共同的都在你手上，
是不是一共手上有50万吧？
那你俩出现矛盾的时候，
每次都是你先动手吗？
不是，
是两个人吵急了也分不清，
就是掐他会弄我脖，
但是不使劲，
我怕他有那个倾向，
你先不说别人，
咱先说自己，
你明明体力上不如人家，
我一直不如人家，
为什么要先动手呢？
就是我是有点感性，
他可能是性格上比较理性，
然后我俩吵起来，
他那个说的把我气急了啊，
可能我父亲有一点暴力，
我自己也在反思，
是不是我有一点暴力啊，
但是我没有使劲那种，
从心理学上来讲呢，
我们确实很容易成为父母的样子，
就是说。
父母脾气不好，
我们也很容易成为脾气不好，
父母有暴力，
我们也很容易成为那个暴力的人。
但是我们之所以要读书，
之所以要修身，
之所以要向那些优秀的人靠拢，
就是我们尽量从我们身边周围的人身上去取其精华，
去其糟粕。
我举一个例子啊，
我自己亲生的例子好不好？
我爸妈都是动手的人，
就他俩相互之间没打过架，
但他俩都打过我们，
然后他俩脾气都不是很好，
都是属于那种好好的话不知道好好说。
比如说我爸要是生病了，
我妈让他去医院的话，
他俩就因为这个事儿能吵起来。
我其实从小就观察他们的相处，
包括爸爸和奶奶的相处，
妈妈和奶奶他们的相处。
我很小很小的时候，
我就想我不要成为这样的人，
我这辈子长大的话，
我绝不成为他们那样的人，
所以当我自己做母亲了之候，
我每一天都在用这个，
我不想成为我妈妈那样的，
我不想成为我爸爸那样的人，
每天都在用这种来约束修炼我自己，
我真的发自内心的跟你们分享我的心路历程，
你自己在一段婚姻里面，
你观察一下你爸妈的相处模式，
他俩有的时候啊，
动手打孩子啊什么的啊，
如果你当小孩的时候，
你受过这样的伤害，
现在我们已经成为大人了，
我们就要成为自己想要的那个父母，
自己想要的那个大人，
就是你们两口子相处的时候，
你想想。
好吧，
你自己想成为一个什么样子的大人，
不是，
这有时候我感觉他也是动手，
我感觉他也有，
那我们可不可以两个人相处的时候，
我们用理性，
用我们彼此的成长去对冲这些东西，
举个例子啊，
也是，
就龙飞姐我老跟大家讲我自己的修炼的过程，
跟大家做参考，
比如说我不喜欢男生跟我相处的时候他说脏话，
那我可能刚开始的时候就特别诚恳的告诉他，
就我俩不管怎么吵，
不管怎么闹，
但是我俩不要说脏话，
因为说脏话是狠，
就是很戳心窝子，
很伤人的这个点啊，
我们就提前约定好，
比如说我不喜欢谁给我surprise，
给我说我走着走着楼梯，
他从楼梯口蹦出来吓我一下，
我说他从背后拍我一下，
我从来都不喜欢这样的事儿，
好，
我就提前跟他说好，
我说你这辈子千万不要吓我，
一旦你吓唬我的话，
可能我对你的信任就一瞬间崩塌了，
从此之后我再也不敢去靠近你了。
好，
那你们两口子啊，
就是借用一下说龙飞的这个经验，
可不可以我俩在聊天的时候非常诚恳的告诉大家说我们一定要做到，
就是不管说怎么生气的话，
我们都不能动手，
一旦动手了之后就伤感情了，
包括我，
我以前如果动过手的话，
我要先跟人家道歉，
我以后再也不在人前的时候掐你了，
你你了，
怎么怎么样了啊，
就是发生矛盾。
啊，
我们就说这矛盾点是什么，
咱就是沟通，
能沟通就沟通，
沟通不了的话咱再说下一步，
但是咱别动手，
就这意思，
先从我自己做起，
他妈妈就是说话有时候说一套字了，
他跟我说是，
那是我们家那个给你买的什么什么，
这是他们私下里是跟他儿子说是要给他买姑娘啊，
我从法律上给你讲啊，
老人他自己的钱呢，
坦率的说啊，
他就算捐了，
他就算埋了，
他就算扔了，
都是他的权利，
就是你们本就不该上来就惦记老人手上的钱，
明白了吧，
法律上是谁我明白，
我知道，
但是我就不舒服的点，
就是他老是就是去跟他儿子就是索求，
然后去做面，
然后但是没有做到一些事儿，
就比如说他花婚礼花20万，
但是他让大家都觉得婚礼也是他花的，
然后车也是他买的，
我就会担心以后怎么跟他交往，
如果说以后生了孩子可能还是需要她帮助，
现在主要是我不知道跟他怎么相处，
就是你们两口子有多大的能耐就过什么样的生活，
不要惦记婆婆手里的钱就好相处，
我不是惦记她，
因为她就是做了很大面子，
然后我们是要给她养老，
我是需要去负担她婆，
我觉得负担的事儿你也别想了，
以你的性格，
你不太可能赡养你的婆婆，
那这事儿的话咱就说。
到头里赡养婆婆这事儿就是你老公的事儿，
你要跟你老公继续过，
就跟你有关系，
你要跟你老公不过了，
就跟你一毛钱关系都没有，
别想那么多，
你不可能赡养婆婆的，
别给自己戴那么大的帽子。
赡养婆婆的事儿就是你老公她自己说了算，
她能挣钱她就赡养啊，
就是我们的钱在一起呢，
她赡养不也得于我赡养？
你这个想法是不对的，
就是你老公她不可能凭空长到30岁，
她不可能不吃一口饭，
不吃一口米，
她就长到30岁，
所以不是说你老公挣的所有的钱都是归你俩的，
你明白吗？
你老公他是从0岁到30岁，
他健健康康能长大，
他是需要父母的投资的，
所以你老公身上背负的赡养父母的义务是法定的，
也就是说，
从法律的规定来看，
你老公挣的钱也得先刨出去赡养父母的钱，
剩下的才是夫妻共同的财产，
而不是说你老公挣来的钱天然的都是夫妻共同财产，
不能拿去赡养父母。
这个逻辑你要搞清处哦，
明明白了，
明白了，
姐啊，
如果姐你再跟我多说几句行了，
我真的挺喜欢你的。
第一，
原生家庭这一头，
你已经成年了，
你已经结婚了，
原生家庭那一头的话，
就是客客气气的相处在自己经济能力范围之内，
礼数上该做到就做到了，
比如说爸爸妈妈过生日，
该发个红包发个红包，
该送点礼物送点礼物，
不要把我自己成年了之后的一些不良的习性和不好的行为。
都推到原生家庭上去，
因为我们之所以是成年人，
就是因为我们有了自我修复，
自我修正的能力，
我们才成为了一个成年人。
不要把所有的坏脾气，
所有的不好的这样一个特征都归罪到原生家庭去，
我们是可以修正自己的，
一定可以的。
如果你没有修正自己的行为，
只是证明你还不够努力去修炼自己。
第二，
如果以后当了妈妈的话，
尽量做一个你小的时候渴望成为的大人，
你小的时候渴望拥有的妈妈。
第三，
跟男人的相处的话，
永远记住不要先动手，
无论发生什么情况，
不要先动手，
不要先动手。
第4，
不要指望公公婆婆给你任何的帮衬，
不指望什么事儿的话，
跟公公婆婆的相处，
尊重你的老公，
你老公他愿意怎么相处就怎么相处，
你不要去破坏他们之间的那种平衡，
嗯，
我我老公就是有点那种情感需求比较低，
好像就是情感上他没有多少情绪价值，
特别特别理性的，
其实理性挺好的。
姑娘，
接下来我要讲的话，
可能你今天此时此刻听你会觉得非常的刺耳，
你会觉得心里面不好受，
但是从长远来看的话，
这个事儿是对你有帮助的。
我非常坦诚的告诉。
诉你啊，
如果你的老公是一个理性的人，
且你的老公愿意接纳你，
愿意跟你去共同孕育子女的话，
你一定要好好珍惜，
如果你老公没有什么别的不良嗜好，
因为你本身的性格并不是特别的招男孩子喜欢，
你本身的性格并不是特别的有性张力，
有女性的魅力和吸引力，
所以说咱能找到一个眼瞎的就好好珍惜，
这个眼瞎的，
可能我就是属于那种太在乎了，
每次我都是去找他沟通，
时间久了，
我也是情感淡淡的那种，
因为淡淡的好姑娘啊。
我接下来有一个观点，
这个观点特别适用于你，
当然也适用于我自己，
我真心的跟姐妹们讲啊，
就是两口子过日子吧，
真的别是那种说哎呀，
就是爱的不得了，
爱的24小时都要黏在一起，
爱的看什么都顺眼，
像这样的两口子过日子的话，
他会遭添妒，
情深不受，
讲的就是这个逻辑，
而两口子之间就是相互哎比较信任，
反正就是两口子相对来说都是淡淡的在一起挺好的啊，
他可能出差了，
我也感觉也挺好，
对我这两口子日子反而过得四平八稳，
平淡，
可幸福了，
你现在这种淡淡的状态就挺好，
你老公对你也淡淡的状态也挺好啊，
再谢谢你，
嗯，
好，
就这样。
拜拜，
姐妹们，
就是有些东西他真的是很玄学的东西，
就是你看那两口子有爱的就是非你不可，
哎呀，
死去活来，
就是天天都想见到呀，
两口子在一起就如条死妻，
就是周围的人都羡慕的不得了，
反而他俩未必，
你知道吗？
情深不寿，
老天爷看不过眼，
但是你说两口子就是那种相互淡淡的，
比较欣赏，
比较信任，
有你我过得更好，
没你的话我也能不好，
反而这俩人过得可长久了。
记得点赞关注哦。